age at 135 pounds is deeply unforgiving
and I do think because of that and the
inactivity he's got an uphill climb on
the other hand it is worth putting some
respect on Henry savuto's name and
saying if there is one guy who could
Buck a trend and he's that guy I would
never bet against him because of here I
think as far as mental mental game goes
there's a few outliers he's one of the
all-time outliers that mental fortitude
but also the changes he can make where
if his original game plan isn't going
well you see between rounds he can make
adjustments and figure out at a very
high level to beat world-class guys he's
coming back right into the mouth of the
lion I mean absolutely at a time when I
mean is anyone going to argue
bantamweight isn't popping right now
yeah I think it's amazing to the point
you raise like even in over a one one's
main event is man some way and it's sick
you know what I mean like that there's
just so much talent there